a guidare a lui tanti auguri sergio e
ragazze credete che senza ce stai
guardando persone allo scoperto
vuoi un po di insalata no grazie non
passa ripenso sono invece con l'insalata
queste le maglie sia quando sull argine
alla cultura per esempio che cos'hanno
oggi avrebbe festeggiato i 17 anni
stavamo sempre insieme due feste in un
dato positivo che se dovesse laurent
tirard affari dalla tomba non avrebbe
bisogno di un costume da zombie
che cos'è
questa che assente ragazze mi puzza di
bruciato e io che pensavo che questo
tempo provenissero a qualcun altro
ragazze secondo me non dovremmo
guardarla magari un documentario sulla
guerra fredda lo scopriremo presto
che cosa abbiamo visto lo so tranquilli
ragazzi ci penso io
pino porto sempre una torcia tenuti da
youtube con la dinamo con me ma che ci
fa seduta so perché non ho trovato
attivo come le capita bocca come
l'insalata al thotel malena ma si sente
bene ha detto che era allergica
all'insana me quindi magari è stato il
profilattico che l'ha uccisa forse per
questo che ci può essere stata girlanda
sì è vero lo diamo perché ci sono non
l'avrei mai uccisà
stai andando prima a cena ti sei fatto
uscire una frase infelice comune capi la
bocca con dell'insalata
questa è la tinto bollati come la
polizia ragazze d'oggi affari usa dove
sia carbonia la chiave
ciao
no gli hanno fatto ascoltare radio maria
qualcuno è dato dalla finestra ma allora
che strano sia ballo sono allergica alla
cultura per esempio siamo stati che
formano la legge popolare
no no no non solo perché ti sei chiusa
qui esci fuori battere sistema desideri
balena grande polonia cosa sta dicendo
assi ti sei allontanato la polonia con
una scusa e questa introduzione al
traguardo l'ipod cara vicino che olanda
era lo stesso cameriera e libro tv
costiere per forza il tuo perché nessuno
di noi sa nemmeno come si scrive bucati
su kw
nonno di nozze o una figlia una città un
cinturino è bello ma con vernice
cafornia dal tornio ci sei
lei
ma chi è una mezza polonia possibile
sei stata tu sei dall'inizio ho mai
fatto è stata molto facile mentre
guardavate quel video sono scivolata via
vi ho chiamato nel buio ho accoltellato
malena balena con una scusa ha
allontanato quella sciacca di calpurnia
dal bagno ecco il punto
all impatto laico radikal fori nel suo
libro di burrasche con la mia si chiama
bukowsky fa niente
ho messo l'ipod milioni di anni che è
morta sul colpo
vado usate il sangue di malena per
fingere di morire in giro da vent
ornamento al basso quando ti sei
rinchiusa nella stanza un messori crocs
ai piedi di carboni l ha fatto tutto da
sola pesa e con la dannata cassetta mi
sembra ovvio
qualche mese fa avevo detto ha senso che
avrei voluto copiare la moda dei pre
diciottesimi ma farne dei saperi e 17
anni
non sapevo mai pensato a gennaio lo so
ma sta gente
avrebbe fatto il comprando prima di me
cosa ha fatto ha copiato l'idea sapendo
che nessuno avrebbe tre domande così mi
sono dovuta vendicare mescolato una
motivazione molto valido per un omicidio
a perché anche noi non avesse proprio
l'idea di un per xvii era troppo
succulenta non ci abbiamo pensato è vero
mi posso permettere che ciò avvenga
perché quel pre 17esimo è meglio non so
cosa dire poi vediamo
prego perdonami troppo tardi marcella è
arrivato il momento di dare lavorano
attenti a te buon halloween marcella